สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 23
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 23
22 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
[เพลง]
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 10 โมง
10 โมงกี่นาที
3 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ 10 นาทีก็ถ้าเราแบ่งเป็นเวลากลางวัน
กับกลางคืน
10 โมงเนี่ยเป็นกลางวันหรือว่ากลางคืนคะ
เป็นกลางวันค่ะ
เป็นเวลากลางวันอันนี้คือเราแบ่งกลางวัน
กลางคืนใช่ไหมคะแต่จริงๆแล้วประเทศไทยเรา
แบ่งมากกว่านี้อีกประเทศไทยมีแบ่งมากกว่า
นี้อีกหรอคะคุณหญิงใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าถ้า
แป๊บนึงนะคะนักเรียนขอเอาอันนี้ออกไปก่อน
ถ้าแบ่งเป็นกลางวันเดี๋ยวครูหญิงเลื่อน
2 อันนี้ขึ้นไปนะ
ใช่ไหมถ้าแบ่งเป็นเวลามีเก็บไปก่อน
เป็นเวลากลางวันสมัยตอนกลางวันก็คือมีดวง
อาทิตย์เนี่ยนะคะกลางวันควีนจะเอาเป็นสี
แดงแล้วกันนะคะนักเรียนกลางวันเนี่ยเราก็
จะมีตอนเช้าใช่ไหมแบ่งเป็นตอนเช้าตอนเช้า
ก็ 6 โมงไหม
ตอนเช้า 6 โมงเช้า
ถึงซักประมาณ 8 โมง
เนาะ
ใช่ค่ะตอนเช้านะคะ
แล้วพอเช้าเสร็จถ้าค่ะ
9 โมงตั้งแต่ 9 โมงถึงประมาณ
11 โมง
คนไทยก็จะบอกว่าเป็นช่วงสายๆไหมเป็นสาย
แล้ว
[เพลง]
เวลาสายตอนครูฟ้าตื่น 10 โมงครูฟ้าตื่น
สาย
ตายแต่ถ้าครูฟ้าตื่น 8 โมง
ตื่นยังเช้าอยู่นะก็ตื่นเช้าเนาะ
แล้วก็ช่วงประมาณซัก 11 โมง
อันนี้ซัก 10 โมงแล้วกันผู้หญิงเปลี่ยน
ใหม่นะคะ
ถึงเที่ยงใช่ไหมคะ
ถึงเที่ยงเนี่ยจริงๆก็คือตอนกลางวันหรือ
ว่าตอนเที่ยงน้องกลางวันเรากินข้าวอ่ะเรา
กินข้าวกลางวันใช่ไหมคนไทยก็เลยเออเนี่ย
กลางวันแล้วเที่ยงแล้ว
แล้วถ้าเป็นบ่ายโมงถึงซักประมาณ 4 โมง
เนาะ
บ่ายโมงถึง 4 โมง
ช่วงบ่าย
เนอะเป็นช่วงบ่ายนะคะบ่ายๆแล้วถ้า 5 โมง
ถึง 6 โมงล่ะคะช่วงเย็นค่ะ
เห็นไหมอันนี้คือเวลากลางวัน
โดยมีตอนเช้า
ตอนสายๆแล้วก็ช่วงกลางวันตอนบ่ายแล้วก็
ตอนเย็น
แต่ถ้าเป็น
เป็นกลางคืนเนี่ยไม่แบ่งเยอะขนาดนี้นะผู้
หญิงคิดว่าว่าทุกคนเนี่ยนอนนะคะ
กลางคืนกลางคืน
อ้าวก็อาจจะมีซัก 1 ทุ่มถึงซัก 20:00 น
ไหม
1 ทุ่มถึง 2 ทุ่ม
1 ทุ่มถึง 2 ทุ่มเนี่ย
ค่ำเหรอคะคนไทยก็จะบอกว่าเป็นหัวค่ำหรือ
ว่าตอนค่ำ
เรายังไม่นอนอาจจะอาบน้ำดูดูทีวีไปดูทีวี
ยังไม่นอนนะคะ
แล้วก็ถ้าช่วงซัก 5 ทุ่มเวลาที่เหลือมัน
ก็จะเป็นตอนกลางคืนนะนักเรียนถ้าช่วงซัก 5
ทุ่มถึงเที่ยงคืน
หรือว่า 4 ทุ่มนะ
[เพลง]
ก็คือนอนดึกใช่ไหมนอนดึก
ตอนกลางคืน
แล้ว
มีอีกไหมคะครูหญิงตอนกลางตอนกลางคืน
ก็เลยไปจนถึงประมาณตี 4 จนถึง
ตี 5 ช่วงนี้อันนี้ที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเช้า
แล้วบางคนเนี่ยตื่นนอนแล้วคนไทยจะบอกว่า
เป็นเช้ามืดนะคะเพราะว่ามันยังเป็นกลาง
คืนอยู่ไงก็จะเป็นเช้ามืดแต่มันก็จะมี
เวลา
หัวค่ำใช่ไหมคะดึกแล้วก็ชาวมืดอันนี้คือ
กลางวันกับกลางคืนนักเรียนรู้จักเวลาแล้ว
ผู้หญิงอยากจะถามครูฟ้าว่าในช่วงเวลากลาง
วันเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ไม่ชอบ
ตอนไหนมากที่สุดในตอนกลางวันตอนเช้าตอน
สายตอนกลางวันตอนบ่ายหรือว่าตอนเย็นครู
ฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบช่วงบ่ายค่ะ
ช่วงบ่ายทำไมอ่ะคะครูฟ้า
เพราะว่า
ช่วงบ่ายเนี่ยราคานักเรียนอากาศมันร้อน
ค่ะ
เซลเซียสหรือเปล่านะคะอากาศร้อนนะคะช่วง
บ่ายแล้วก็
ช่วงบ่ายเป็นเวลาที่
รู้สึกเหนื่อย
ง่ายๆ
ใช่ไหมแบบฟังเพราะว่าช่วงกลางวันหรือว่า
ตอนเที่ยงเนี่ยเรากินข้าวแล้วมันก็อิ่ม
เสร็จแล้วเราก็ต้องกลับมาทำงานใช่ไหมช่วง
บ่ายเนี่ยทำงานทำงานมันจะรู้สึกว่า
ทำไมเวลานานจังเมื่อไหร่จะตอนเย็น
เนาะ
อยากนอนด้วย
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าก็เลยไม่ชอบช่วงบ่ายมากที่
สุดจริงๆเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบตื่นเช้านะคะ
นักเรียน
ไม่ชอบตื่นใช่ไหมตื่นเช้า
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าชอบตอนเช้าไง
ไม่ได้บอกกูไม่ได้ถามนี่ว่าครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
ตื่นใช่ไหมคะแกบอกกูฟังไม่ชอบเวลาไหนแต่
ถ้าเป็นกลางคืนเนี่ยครูหญิงคิดว่าครูฟ้า
ชอบทั้งหมดนะคะ 100%
ไม่นอนเลยนะคะ 1 ทุ่มถึง 2 ทุ่มเนี่ยก็
เป็นเวลาที่กำลังกินข้าวอยู่นะคะนักเรียน
แล้วก็ 4 ทุ่มถึงเที่ยงคืนเนี่ยก็เล่นไม่
ได้เล่นเกมอ่านหนังสือนะคะแล้วก็ตอนบ่าย
โมงนักเรียนเนี่ยตื่นครูหญิงเนี่ยตื่นตอน
เช้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนพอดีนอนพอดีหรือไม่ก็
จะเปิดโทรศัพท์นะคะก็สั่งอาหารนะคะข้าว
เหนียวหมูปิ้งใน Grab  food
แล้วก็กินแสดงประมาณ 9:00 น
นอนช่วงสายๆเหรอคะช่วงสายๆนอนช่วงสายๆนะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นช่วงเวลาใช่ไหมคะเวลาที่
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบใช่ไหมในช่วงตอนกลางวันแล้ว
ครูหญิงนะคะครูหญิงไม่ชอบเวลาไหนมากที่
สุด
ครูหญิงไม่ชอบเวลาไหนมากที่สุดหรอ
ผู้หญิงน่าจะไม่ชอบตอนเช้าค่ะครูฟ้าทำไม
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงคิดถึงที่ครูฟ้าพูดไง
ไม่ชอบตอนเช้าเพราะว่าถ้ามีคนบอกว่าผู้
หญิงต้องตื่นตอนเช้า
อยากนอนนานๆผู้หญิงชอบตื่นสายนะคะชอบตื่น
ประมาณสักช่วงสายๆหน่อย 9 โมงอย่างเงี้ย
ชอบ
มากกว่ากำลังดีใช่ไหมเพราะว่าตอน 6 โมง
เช้าถึง 8 โมงเช้าช่วงเช้าเนี่ยนะคะนอน
สบายมาก
ใช่ค่ะช่วงสายๆเนี่ยตื่นมาอาบน้ำแปรงฟัน
แล้วก็กินข้าวเสร็จแล้วเดี๋ยวก็กลางวัน
กินข้าวอีกแล้วนะคะแล้วก็ช่วงบ่ายก็นอน
[เพลง]
ช่วงบ่ายก็นอนต่อได้ใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ร้อนเหรอ
อ้าวเปิดแอร์ค่ะที่บ้านมีแอร์นะคะ
อันนี้คือช่วงเวลานะคะซึ่งเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
มันไม่มีนาฬิกาใช่ไหมตอนนี้เรามีนาฬิกา
ใช่ไหมที่จะมีเข็มสั้นแล้วก็เข็มยาวใช่
ไหม 12  3  6  9 เนี่ยเราดูเวลากี่โมงกี่
โมงใช่ไหมคะแต่เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเราไม่ได้ดู
เวลาจากนาฬิกาเราดูจากดวงอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคน
ไทยอ่ะก็เลยเรียกเป็นตอนเช้าตอนสายตอน
กลางวันตอนบ่ายแล้วก็ตอนเย็นแบ่งใหญ่นะคะ
พอมีเวลาแล้วเนี่ยมันก็ต้องมีวันใช่ไหมคะ
วัน
ใน 1 อาทิตย์ใน 1 ปีดีกว่าใน 1 ปี
1 ปีเนี่ยมีกี่วันคะครูฟ้าใน 1 ปีเนี่ย
นะคะมี
365 วันค่ะ
ใน 1 ปีมี 365 วันมีกี่เดือนมี
12 เดือน
อ่ามีกี่อาทิตย์
ไม่ทราบ
52 ไง
1 ปีเนี่ยมี 365 วันมี 12 เดือนมี 52
ประมาณนะประมาณนะคะมี 52 อาทิตย์
[เพลง]
คุณอยากจะถามครูฟ้าว่า
ใน 1 ปีมี 365 วันมี 52 อาทิตย์ใช่ไหมใน 1
อาทิตย์มีกี่วัน
ใน
1 อาทิตย์มี 7 วันนะ
ใน 1 อาทิตย์
มี 7 วันนะคะถูกแล้วค่ะ
ไม่ชอบวันไหนมากที่สุด
ครูฟ้าชอบวันไหนเนี่ย
นักเรียนรู้หรือยังไม่รู้นะแต่ว่าครูฟ้า
ไม่ชอบวันไหนใน 7 วันจันทร์อังคารพุธ
พฤหัสบดีศุกร์เสาร์อาทิตย์ 7 วันครูฟ้า
ไม่ชอบแบบไม่ชอบวันไหนมากที่สุด
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
วันไหนมากที่สุดนะคะ
มีไหมคะที่ภูฟ้าแบบไม่ชอบ
จริงๆปกติครูฟ้าก็ไม่ค่อยชอบวันจันทร์นะ
คะนักเรียนทำไมสีชมพู
วันจันทร์ต้องสีเหลืองสิครูฟ้า
แต่คุณฟ้าไม่ชอบวันพุธค่ะ
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบวันพุธทำไม
ไม่ชอบวันพุธนะคะเพราะว่าวันจันทร์เนี่ย
นะคะนักเรียนมันก็โอเคใช่ไหมเราทำงานก็
ยังโอเควันอังคาร
ก็ยังโอเคนะคะแต่พอวันพุธเนี่ยฟ้าจะ
เหนื่อยมาก
ทำงานวันที่ 3 เริ่มเหนื่อยใช่ไหมก็เลย
ไม่ชอบวันพุธใช่ค่ะ
วันศุกร์
นะคะ
มันก็เลยไม่ชอบวันพุธเพราะว่ารู้สึกว่า
เป็นวันที่เหนื่อย
ก็เลยไม่ชอบมากที่สุดก็คือวันพุธแล้วถ้า
เป็นเดือนละคะ 12 เดือน 12 เดือนเนาะใน 1
ปีเนี่ย
มี 12 เดือนอ่ะลบไป
มี 12 เดือนเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ชอบนะเอาชอบก่อนชอบเดือนไหนมากที่สุด
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะแน่นอนว่าทุกคนรู้
โลกรู้นะ
ทำไมคะทำไมถึงชอบเดือนธันวาคมมากที่สุด
เพราะว่าเดือนธันวาคมมีคริสต์มาสนะคะ 1
เลยคือมีวัน
คริสต์มาส 2 นะคะอากาศหนาว
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันจะมาสัก
20-28 องศาเซลเซียสนะมันหนาวมันเย็น
มี Happy  Birthday ครูฟ้านะคะในเดือน
ธันวาคม
เกิดเดือนธันวาคมด้วยใช่ไหมคะงั้นครูหญิง
ก็รู้แล้วค่ะว่าพระเดือนที่ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
มากที่สุดเดือนเมษายนใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงรู้ได้ยังไง
ก็ครูฟ้าชอบเดือนธันวาคมอากาศหนาวก็เดือน
เมษายนเนี่ยมันตรงข้ามกันไงคะมันร้อน
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยได้ถึง 40 ถึง 44 ได้นะ
องศาเซลเซียสนะคะทุกวันใช่ไหมมันร้อนครู
ฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบเดือนเมษายนมากที่สุดไม่ชอบนะ
ก็ชอบเดือนเมษายนนิดหน่อยเพราะว่ามันมี
ทุเรียนนะ
มันมีผลไม้ไทยนะคะนักเรียนเนี่ย
ทุเรียนนะคะ
[เพลง]
เดือนเมษายนมีทุเรียนมากๆนะคะ
อีก 1 คำถามแล้วกันนะคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยใน
แต่ละอันนี้ไม่เอาเดือนนะกลับมาที่วันของ
เราต่อดีกว่าค่ะใน 1 อาทิตย์เนี่ยมี 7
วันใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็บอกว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
ชอบวันพุธไม่ชอบวันพุธใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่า
เป็นวันทำงานวันที่ 3 ในเพราะว่าปกติแล้ว
เนี่ยใน 7 วันเนี่ยเราจะทำงาน
5 วัน 5 วันเนี่ย
อังคารพุธพฤหัสบดีแล้วก็สุขเนี่ยเป็นวัน
ทำงาน 5 วันแล้วอีก 2 วันก็คือวันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์ 2 วันเนี่ยก็จะเป็นวันหยุดใช่
ไหมคะบางครั้งเป็นวันหยุดเสาร์อาทิตย์วัน
หยุดสุดสัปดาห์เราเนี่ยไม่ต้องทำงาน
เพราะว่ามันบดอาทิตย์ละวันหยุดสุดสัปดาห์
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
ปกติ
ครูฟ้าทำอะไรในวันหยุดเสาร์อาทิตย์ในวัน
หยุดเสาร์อาทิตย์นี้นะคะปกติแล้วเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าก็จะอยู่ที่บ้านนะคะนักเรียน
ฟ้าคือไม่ทำอะไรนะคะ
อยู่ที่บ้านนะคะ
จริงๆเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยาใช่ไหมล่ะ
บ้านที่พัทยา
ถ้าอยู่พัทยาเนี่ยอยู่ที่บ้านแล้วก็
เปิด Notebook นะคะ
เล่นเกมบ้าง
เล่นโซเชียลบ้างดู netflix นะคะแล้วก็หา
อะไรอร่อยๆกินวันเสาร์อาทิตย์เนี่ยจะเป็น
วันที่กูฟ้าเอ็นจอย eating มากๆเลยนะคะ
เราจะเข้าแอพพลิเคชั่น Grab  Good แล้วก็
กิน
อะไรที่อยากกินมากๆในวันเสาร์อาทิตย์อ๋อ
เพราะว่าไม่ต้องทำงานใช่ไหมถ้าวันจันทร์
ถึงวันศุกร์เนี่ยเป็นวันทำงานไม่มีเวลา
ไม่มีเวลาเปิดดูร้านนี้อร่อยมาก
กินเร็วๆแต่ถ้าเป็นวันหยุดเสาร์อาทิตย์
โอ้โหไม่ต้องทำงานมีเวลามากๆ
ก็เช็คได้เอ๊ะกินอะไรดีนะกูฝากก็เลยมี
เวลาหาของอร่อยๆกินใช่ค่ะคุณหญิงมันก็เลย
จะให้ความสำคัญกับเรื่องกินคือว่าจะชอบ
กินมากๆนะคะในวันเสาร์อาทิตย์นะคะแล้วจะ
หาอะไรกินแต่ถ้าอยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหม
อยู่กรุงเทพฯวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์หรือว่า
วันหยุดเนี่ยนะวันหยุดสุดสัปดาห์ครูฟ้าทำ
อะไรอ่ะคะเสาร์อาทิตย์เนี่ยถ้าอยู่
กรุงเทพฯก็จะหยิบโทรศัพท์นะคะแล้วก็โทรหา
เพื่อน
ฮัลโหลเพื่อน
ไปฮัลโหล
เปิดคาเฟ่ไปดื่มกาแฟดื่มน้ำ
หรอ
ไปนั่งเล่น
ไม่ได้ไปดื่มกาแฟไม่ได้ไปดื่ม expresso
อเมริกาโน่จริงๆนะ
คาเฟ่ในกรุงเทพฯคาเฟ่ในประเทศไทยนะคะ
ไม่อร่อยแต่ว่าสวย
สวย
แต่ว่าก็นั่งฟรีก็ไม่ได้นะมีต้นคริสต์มาส
อย่างนี้
แล้วก็ไปแบบถ่ายรูปร้านสวยๆใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
ถ่ายรูปงานสวยๆนะคะแต่ว่า
เค้ก
แพงน้ำ
แผงนะคะและไม่อร่อยนะคะนักเรียนแต่ครูฟ้า
ก็ต้องสั่งนะฟ้าจะสั่งน้ำ 1 แก้วแล้วก็
เค้ก 1 ชิ้น
วาดรูปสิค่ะ
อันนี้ก็คือวันหยุดสุดสัปดาห์เนาะหรือว่า
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์สิ่งที่ครูฟ้าทำนะคะ
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะวันจันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์
เนี่ยนักเรียนทำงานเนาะเป็นวันทำงานแล้ว
วันหยุดสุดสัปดาห์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์นัก
เรียนทำอะไรอยู่บ้านหรือว่าไปคาเฟ่หาอะไร
อร่อยกินไหมเกาะคอมเมนต์บอกเราได้เนาะ
สวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]